a crackdown on dangerous drivers across
the valley leading to more than a dozen
arrests street racing part of the focus
of a specialized team with metro police
and one area that is seeing a trend is
in the northwest part of the valley and
that's where we find madison kimbrell
live tonight with the details
metro covering a lot of ground across
the valley as racing continues to be an
issue like right here on iron mountain
road and sky canyon
park drive and recently the racing
apprehension and intervention detail
unit has made several arrests on our
roadways
when i hear a car going really really
fast i almost brace
like am i going to hear the brakes am i
going to hear the skidding am i going to
hear something yeah the fear is
definitely real especially if my kids
are in the backyard and i hear
screeching tires a wall that's all
that's keeping residents in this
northwest valley neighborhood safe from
a speeding car plowing through as racing
cars can be heard throughout the day and
night just the road outside here speed
limits 40. we'll hear people
ripping down like it's no big deal i
mean some people squeeze the red light
here like it's no big deal metro police
taking action just last night their raid
detectives arrested 21 suspects
including drivers and spectators 13
vehicles and five firearms were also
impounded this happened on u.s 93 just
outside of town father of five paul
miller says he has called metro police
for help before in relation to racing in
his neighborhood and he's glad action is
being taken cars are just doing donuts
smoke everywhere kids in the street
sitting on the car just get a presence
out there and and just
disperse people before someone gets hurt
i mean when are they going to stop
and according to metro there have been a
71.4 percent spike this year in
excessive speed for factors in fatal
wrecks if you have any tips about a
street racing or reckless driving
incident you can call metro you can also
email them that's at raid
lvmpd.com reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now